dazu seien herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live im live stream zu aktuellen
diskussionen und ereignissen das ist
hier im netz ganz schön ungemütlich
werden kann das weiß irgendwie
wahrscheinlich jeder der sich hier aktiv
beteiligt oder aktiv mitliest besonders
aber frauen kriegen das immer wieder zu
spüren
geschlechtsbezogene digitale gewalt die
ist ziemlich real auch wenn sie im
digitalen raum stattfindet da wird ja
auch immer manchmal so getan als ob das
dann nicht echt wer das steht unter
anderem auch im gutachten für den
dritten gleichstellungsbericht der
bundesregierung das hat das
bundeskabinett heute miteinander
besprochen da gibt's stellungnahmen aus
den einzelnen ministerien die wurden
heute beschlossen geht dann als nächstes
in den bundestag und in den bundesrat
und wenigen das zum anlass um mal über
dieses thema zu reden wie
frauenfeindlich ist das netz eigentlich
das machen wir unter anderem mit
josefine ballon die ist leiterin der
rechtsberatung bei der ngo headache dort
org dort können sich betroffene zu hilfe
melden und hilfe bekommen und mit susi
crime feministische aktivistin und
content kreaturen unter anderem für
sagen wir erwachsenen inhalte früher war
sie auch mal für das zdf tätig für die
funk sendung jäger und sammler und ich
hoffe ich sehe ist jetzt beide bei mir
auf dem bildschirm da sind sie herzlich
willkommen
ich ahne schon dass es in den
kommentaren hoch hergehen kann das
königliche tab bei uns explodiert auch
trat schon wir gehen wir gleich darauf
ein wie wir das immer machen wir nehmen
das mit ihnen auf ich bitte trotzdem
schön sagt nicht zu bleiben bei diesem
thema und wenn ihr eine e mail schreiben
wollt geht das auch und zwar an dieser
adresse hier jetzt hätte erfreute - live
at zdf.de na wo kommt sie kommt gleich
noch könnt ihr euch auch merken frau
ballon da ist sie ist das phänomen dass
jetzt vermehrt in den blick genommen
wird hass im netz besonders gegen frauen
ist es immer schon da gewesen und wir
gucken mehr drauf oder wird dass
tatsächlich mehr
nach unserem empfinden wird es dann
nicht mehr
wir haben natürlich insgesamt schon seit
2005 den einer gewisser mario der
sprache im netz wahrgenommen auch im
zusammenhang mit der sogenannten
flüchtlingen lese und das lässt mich
jetzt eben ort und für gegen eben
vermehrt auch im zusammenhang mit der
panini auch angriffe gegen frauen in den
letzten monaten die sich nach unserem
befinden
durchaus vermehrt haben obwohl wir das
natürlich nicht wissenschaftlich belegen
können sondern nur für die sprechen
können die sich auch an uns wenden bei
mir kommen sie gerade ein bisschen
leiser rüber ich weiß nicht wie das da
draußen ist wir arbeiten vielleicht noch
mal dran programm wie nehmen sie das
denn wahr ist es mehr geworden oder
gucken wir nur mehr hin
ich glaube dass wir vorher
wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht so die
möglichkeit hatten da hinzuschauen wenn
es gerade um sexistische gewalt gegen
frauen im netz geht weil die
digitalisierung ja noch gar nicht so
weit vorangeschritten ist also irgendwie
steckt noch in den kinderschuhen und
social media plattformen wie twitter und
instagram hatten sind entweder vor zehn
jahren noch gar nicht existent gewesen
oder es gab einfach noch nicht so viele
nutzer darauf deswegen ist es
wahrscheinlich etwas das mit der sache
an sich mit kommt und ein problem mit
dem wir uns jetzt erst beschäftigen
müssen das gutachten der
sachverständigen kommission für diesen
gleichstellungsbericht der kommt zu dir
das kommt zu dem schluss dass diese
digitale gewalt sehr vielfältig sein
kann auch in sehr verschiedenen formen
in sehr verschiedenen szenarien
stattfinden kann und rené severin hat
das mal für uns zusammengefasst
digitale gewalt gegen frauen ein thema
im netz das auch die politik beschäftigt
im gutachten zum aktuellen
gleichstellungsbericht
das ist ein schlimmes phänomene sich da
entwickelt das wir merken dass hass und
hetze zum beispiel im netz sich explizit
gegen frauen richtet dieser frauen hass
im netz schritt im gutachten zufolge in
verschiedenen bereichen auf erstens
politik und ehrenamt äußern frauen sich
beispielsweise offen politisch folgen
häufig frauenfeindliche beleidigungen
bis hin zu morddrohungen
zweitens im beruf durch cyber
belästigung am arbeitsplatz also
sexualisierte oder pornografische
inhalte von arbeitskollegen aber auch
hass kommentare die vor allem frauen in
öffentlichen berufen wie in florenz
darin erhalten außerdem digitale gewalt
im sozialen raum wenn frauen zum
beispiel immer wieder direkt
unerwünschte nachrichten auf social
media erhalten beispiele sind cyber
stalking oder drohungen beispielsweise
nacktfotos zu verbreiten zuletzt der
öffentliche raum außerhalb des internets
die gefahren so genanntes ups körting
oder ungewollt intime aufnahmen die dann
im netz landen die lösungen aktuell vor
allem
aufklärungskampagnen oder
beratungsangebote wie hilft telefone das
problem eine wahrscheinlich hohe
dunkelziffer außerdem fehlende
kompetenzen und kapazitäten bei den
ermittlungsbehörden
momentan ist tatsächlich das eine große
ein graubereich wo man nicht genau weiß
wo man wohin man damit gehen sollte man
wir haben große also es gibt große
wissenslücken in der wissens
schnittstelle zwischen
fachberatungsstellen und der polizei
beziehungsweise
gerichte und strafverfolgungs
institution das heißt empfehlen wir eine
stärkere kooperation dieser
unterschiedlichen zuständigkeiten das
gutachten empfiehlt also vor allem eins
kompetenzen zum umgang mit digitaler
gewalt stärken bei möglichen opfern und
behörden und schnellere und einfachere
möglichkeiten für opfer digitale gewalt
zu melden uns endgültig aus dem internet
zu löschen
so bin ich jetzt in die kommentare gucke
da wird es gleich schon ich sag mal hott
nicht unbedingt positiven sinne ich
nehme es einmal beispielhaft den
kommentar von norman wo ist der ist mir
gerade schmiede weggerutscht da und das
hat natürlich nur was damit zu tun dass
es eine frau ist wie pauschal kann man
sich bitte angegriffen fühlen da geht
die frage an frau ballon als
rechtsexpertin und juristinnen wie kann
man denn das unterscheiden ob das jetzt
tatsächlich ich sage mal sexistische
digitale gewalt ist oder in herrn
führungs zeichen einfach nur digitale
gewalt oder tatsächlich auch kritik
wir sehen ganz klar dass es einen
strukturellen unterschied gibt zwischen
der digitalen gewalt die zu - teterow
sexuelle weise männer erhalten im
vergleich zu dem was frauen erhalten es
ist nicht nur so dass die inhalte mit
denen sich frauen an uns wenden
wesentlich häufiger auch rechtlich
relevant sind sondern wir sehen auch
dass sich ein drittel der inhalte mit
denen sich frauen an uns wenden allein
gegen ihr aussehen gegen ihr geschlecht
richten und meistens sexualisiert und
und das ist etwas was männer in dieser
form nicht erleben da sehen wir viel
häufiger dass es auch eine
auseinandersetzung eine kritische
auseinandersetzung mit inhalten gibt
wird der arbeit mit positionen aber eben
nicht das einfach nur unter die
gürtellinie gefeiert wird und das ist
etwas was ich durch unsere gesamte
beratung zieht wo wir sehen dass ein der
strukturelle unterschied da ist jemand
unbedingt genauer untersuchen sollte
könnte das denn wirklich mit sicherheit
sagen dass männer das nicht erleben kann
es vielleicht auch nicht sein dass
männer dann einfach nicht zu ihnen
kommen und das vielleicht ja weg stecken
oder in sich rein fressen und sich eben
nicht damit aktiv auseinandersetzen
ich kann wie gesagt natürlich nur für
die menschen sprechen die sich an uns
wenden allerdings ist es auch teil
unserer arbeit die kommentarspalten zu
durchsuchen für bestimmte personen und
da eben auch nachzuschauen was ist da so
rein gekommen was könnte möglicherweise
justiziabel sein und in unserer beratung
ist auch in etwa die hälfte
sind die hälfte in etwa männer das heißt
in der beratung sehen wir dass der
frauenanteil nur etwas eher geringfügig
erhöht ist mit 58 prozent also nicht so
signifikant hoch aber in der
prozesskosten finanzierung da sind es
dann eben drei viertel frauen weil die
inhalte mit denen frauen zu uns kommen
eben dann auch rechtlich verfolgbar sind
weil sie schlicht illegal sind programm
wie ist das bei ihnen wie oft würden sie
sagen erfahren sie im schnee digitale
gewalt
ich würde sagen definitiv täglich also
es gab auch jeden fall mal eine zeit
während man der influenza karriere wo
das wesentlich mehr war als es das heute
ist es ist tatsächlich ein bisschen
ruhiger geworden aber es ist trotzdem
immer noch ein präsenter teil meines
alltags also gerade diese sexualisierte
gewalt von der gesprochen wird da sind
eigentlich kommentare über mein aussehen
oder mein gewicht oder so das kann man
da noch er wegstecken was einem dann
wirklich angst macht auch dass der hass
quasi vom digitalen von dem digitalen
raum in den privaten offline raum rüber
sucht sind tatsächlich
gewaltandrohungen also gewaltandrohungen
von sexualisierter gewalt
nun muss man ganz kurz zu sagen das
kommt ja immer wieder in diesen
diskussionen es gibt das auch gegen
männer ja es gibt das auch gegen männer
ich kann da aus meiner perspektive auch
sagen mir ist das auch schon passiert
dass mir
userin und dann eigentlich eigentlich
nur user muss ich sagen aus meiner
erfahrung sachen geschrieben haben die
ich nicht sehen wollte und das ist in
meinem langen jahren im internet sehr
sehr selten vorgekommen trotzdem gibt es
ja auch gerade einen kommentar ich bin
heute von einer frau belästigt worden wo
kann ich mich melden hier von patrick
hayek tatsächlich also ob das jetzt
stimmt oder nicht weiß ich nicht ich
nehme es jetzt mal ernst du kannst nicht
melden weil jeder polizeidienststelle du
kannst dich bei hague dort melden das
ist also nichts was irgendwie nur frauen
auf den stets wenn du dich belästigt
fühlt werden du dich sexuell belästigt
gefühlt hast ist es definitiv einen weg
sich auch zu melden aber ich kriege hier
gerade wenn wir ins community tab gucken
wo ich mir da schon die auf dem rechner
sind sehr viel kritik ihnen gegenüber
frau crime ich nehme das mal parade als
paradebeispiel das erste hier wieso
ladet ihr eine person ein welcher ein
paradebeispiel für hetze und hass im
internet ist welche fakten ihrer meinung
anpasst und nicht umgekehrt wie man es
eigentlich tun wollte und viele
kommentatoren gehen immer wieder auf
ihre ihr format männer hassen
das ja doch auch sehr kontrovers
diskutiert wurde ist dann tatsächlich so
ein format so zu nennen ist das
förderlich für eine gewaltfreie
kommunikation im netz das ist natürlich
eine us kritische frage die man total
stellen kann und was definitiv eine
konversation ist die ich jetzt wo ich 30
bin auf jeden fall wesentlich mehr
bereit bin zu haben als ich das in
meinem lied one piece war und einfach
verrückten satire content im internet
gemacht habe jedoch finde ich auch finde
ich ist es auch da wiederum sehr
auffällig dass
frauen da irgendwie nimmt double
standard entgegnen wenn sie in der
öffentlichkeit stehen also bei comedians
oder anderen männlichen person in der
öffentlichkeit ist es völlig okay wenn
sie sich einem sehr schwarzem zynischen
humor bedienen und satire machen und
damit auch dritte verteilen und sobald
eine frau ist wagt sich die satire oder
schwarzem humor zu bedienen und das habe
ich mit dem wort männer hast damals
gemacht weil man viel ministerin ja
immer automatisch vorwirft dass sie
männer hasser sind und ich wollte quasi
einen witz daraus machen hat nicht so
gut geklappt findet auf jeden fall ganz
spannend dass
das ja frauen in dem sinne nicht die
gleiche freiheit gegeben wird aber ich
jetzt im format noch grübeln männer auch
nachdenken das ist sehr sehr ernst
gemeint war ist offensichtlich ein
scherz sei aber wenn ich jetzt ein
format machen würde das frauenhaus heißt
und sage ist satire dann würde ich
wahrscheinlich auch einen ziemlichen
schützt vorm bekommen oder ja ich denke
weil ich denke gute satire und gute
comedy und guter humor ist immer der
humor der nach unten tritt der der nach
oben tritt und nicht nach unten und
insofern ist natürlich ein anderer
historischer kontext gegeben ich denke
mal das kann man auch auf themen die mit
race zu tun haben über spiegeln wenn
schwarze menschen witze über weiße
menschen machen halte ich das für
wesentliche gesellschaftliche
akzeptabler als wenn weiße menschen
lieber schwarze menschen witze machen
weil einfach der historische hinterbau
dann ganz ganz anderes leiden dahinter
hat das ist meine perspektive ich
verstehe aber dass leute das inhaltlich
kritisieren und die das vielleicht sehr
geschmacklos finden als humor dass es
durchaus etwas worüber man sprechen kann
was ich nicht nachvollziehen kann und
was ich auch nicht korrekt finde ist
dass dieser vorwand dann genommen wird
um über jahre irgendwie digitale gewalt
an mir zu verüben und frühe eigentlich
alles was ich gemacht habe war ein
satire format in dem ich mich darüber
lustig gemacht habe das ist wirklich
männer gibt die ungewollte schwanz fotos
im internet verschicken und dass man
sich so darüber aufregt
wenn der schuh passt
wie reagiert man dann am besten frau
ballon auf so was also gerade auch so
digitale sexuelle gewalt aber auch ganz
klar person der personifizierte gewalt
wo die menschen direkt angegriffen
würden
in erster linie kann ich sagen dass
betroffene nicht persönlich nehmen
sollten wenn es geht in den
allerseltensten fällen um die person es
geht meistens darum ein exempel zu
statuieren um eine abschreckende wirkung
auch auf andere die sich möglicherweise
im netz frei äußern wollen zu
gesellschaftlich relevanten themen zu
erzielen auf der anderen seite muss man
natürlich auch überlegen wie man
persönlich damit umgeht und da sind die
methoden tatsächlich sehr sehr
unterschiedlich und der sehr individuell
was menschen in dieser mut kann wirklich
er variieren in jedem fall wenn wir es
mit strafbaren inhalten zu tun haben und
auch nur potenziell strafbaren das kann
man ja natürlich immer zu 100 prozent
genau beurteilen kann ich nur dazu raten
sie auch zur anzeige zu bringen und das
nicht einfach hinzunehmen und wirklich
zu akzeptieren dass das was man da
erlebt nicht normal ist dass das nicht
die neue art ist wie wir miteinander
umgehen sondern dass man dagegen etwas
unternehmen sollte und dass vor allem
betroffene auch anerkennen dass sie da
eine gewalterfahrung gemacht haben weil
er sich auch gerne hilfe suchen können
was ist also gewalt erfahrungen ist ist
es schon das steht auch ganz klar ein
gutachten das ist eine gewalt erfahrung
vielleicht mal aus der perspektive der
betroffenen frau bleiben viele sagen ja
immer ja doch nicht so das ist halt
steht ja nur im netz wie kann man sich
das vorstellen
tatsächlich wenn so viele kommentare
gegen einen persönlich gerichtet werden
fühlt sich das tatsächlich an wie gewalt
das ist auf jeden fall psychische und
emotionale gewalt definitiv ich möchte
mich jetzt hier auch überhaupt nicht als
opfer darstellen würde aber auch nie im
leben behaupten dass das total spurlos
an mir vorbei gegangen ist wenn ich
gewusst hätte dass damals mein satire
format so eine reaktion vom internet
ausgelöst hätte dann hätte ich mir
vermutlich in anderen titel hab mir
überlegt
es ist aber tatsächlich auch so das ist
ja nicht bei den angriffen im digitalen
space bleibt also ab dem zeitpunkt wo
das so ein schneeball effekt ist das
einfach immer mehr und mehr und mehr
leute dazukommen
ja so mobben im internet und so
fertigmachen schwab das tatsächlich auch
ins offline leben und ins private leben
überall so ich wurde zum beispiel auch
schon geboxt also meine persönlichen
privaten daten wurden veröffentlicht ich
musste mehrfach meine telefonnummer
wechseln und dann kriegen natürlich
solche vergewaltigungsdrohungen die man
im internet kriegt und täglich liest
kriegen da natürlich noch mal eine ganz
ganz andere schwere wo man tatsächlich
existenzangst hat also das klingt
vielleicht für leute die das noch nicht
erlebt haben irgendwie albern aber das
ist nicht das nehme ich wahr ist
tatsächliche bedrohung weil ich nicht
weiß ob vielleicht morgen jemand vor
meiner haustüre steht ich hab ja auch
eine nachricht von panther bohne
kommentar alle männer die sich hier
angegriffen fühlen haben safe noch nie
dick bekommen oder wurden auf übelste
fertig gemacht oder sogar bedroht falls
man eine dm von einem ekelhaften typen
bekommt also das ist tatsächlich was wo
ich glaube ich auch jetzt als man sagen
kann das ist also etwas das kann man als
mann schwer nachvollziehen wenn man das
mal passiert was mir schon passiert ist
dann hat man eine ganz leichte ahnung
wie sich das für frauen einführen muss
es gibt ja aber das haben wir in diesem
in diesem gutachten gesehen ganz
verschiedene bereiche die betroffenen
sind von solcher digitaler gewalt ein
bereich ist die politik und da gab es
gleich am anfang dieser woche wieder ein
ganz aktuelles beispiel die
grünen-politikerin ricarda lang ist da
das opfer geworden
ricarda lang 27 grüne politikerin und
für manche offenbar ein hassobjekt
während und nach einem auftritt bei der
ard talkshow hart aber fair anfang der
woche hagelte es schmähungen
ihr habt hoffentlich für einen
ordentlichen burger vorrat gesorgt so
einer der mittlerweile gelöschten tweet
wird aus dem mcdonalds übertragen und
die wird ja auch immer dicker ekelhafte
tussi
angriffe also auf das äußere nicht auf
äußerungen aber es gibt auch dass
solidarität auch vom politischen gegner
die angriffe sind einfach nur asozial
twitter zum beispiel paul signac solchen
hass verurteile ich ricarda lang bedankt
sich es bedeutet mir viel zu sehen was
für solidarität möglich ist auch über
parteigrenzen hinweg
und sie fügt hinzu so und jetzt lasst
uns darüber sprechen wie wir die zukunft
gestalten
frau ballon jetzt ist natürlich die
politik ein hartes geschäft da wird mit
harten bandagen gekämpft von allen
seiten wo ist denn da die grenze
zwischen ich sag mal saftiger vielleicht
auch polemischer kritik und tatsächlich
hast das ist auch das was hier immer
wieder thematisiert wird ja das ist
richtig dass man natürlich im
sogenannten politischen meinungskampf
wie es dann bei den gerüchten heißt mehr
aushalten muss und sich auch teilweise
mehr gefallen lassen muss wenn es eben
darum geht dass sich die bürger innen
mit den eigenen positionen auseinander
setzen allerdings bedeutet das nicht
dass man sich beleidigen lassen muss
dass man straftaten dulden muss dass man
sich wüst beschimpfen lassen muss mit
fäkalsprache und vor allem ist die
grenze meistens dann überschritten wenn
nicht nur sich fäkalsprache bedient wird
sondern wenn es tatsächlich auch gar
keine auseinandersetzung mit dem thema
mehr gibt das heißt wenn es wirklich nur
noch darum geht die person zu
diskreditieren sie herunter zu machen
und herabzuwürdigen in der
öffentlichkeit dann haben wir in der
regel auch bei politiker innen schon mit
beleidigungen zu tun und natürlich auch
dann wenn lügen über diese menschen
verbreitet werden wo es ja dann eben
auch gezielt darum geht ihre politische
legitimation zu untergraben dann haben
wir es häufig auch mit verleumdungen zu
tun genauso strafbar sind so jetzt
interessant finde ich dass sie besonders
männer sich über dieses thema
echauffieren ich habe das gefühl es ist
eher so eine abwehrreaktion gerade
zum beispiel von marcel stellt euch vor
ich bin ein mann habe auch schon dick
picks im internet gesehen und stellt
euch vor ich habe es geschafft ist zu
ignorieren und zu löschen ein anderer
kommentar von harry hat habe ich hier
gerade gesehen es ging in die richtung
block doch einfach löschen glocken
ignorieren ist es was was sie empfehlen
würden frau ballon das einfach weg zu
also weg zu ignorieren
nein natürlich nicht das was wir auch
gar keinen fall empfehlen können im
gegenteil man sollte sich eben auch
überlegen ob man nicht
insbesondere bei krassen fällen auch
über eine strafanzeige nachdenken möchte
und vor allem sollte man eben nicht das
einfach so hinnehmen und womöglich noch
verschweigen und so tun als wäre es
jetzt eben etwas was man heutzutage
aushalten muss das ist überhaupt gar
nicht der fall man hat rechtliche
möglichkeiten sich dagegen zu wehren
aber auf der anderen seite hat man
natürlich auch die möglichkeiten bei
sozialen netzwerken solche kommentare zu
melden dann wird sie dann im idealfall
auch entfernt werden es hat natürlich
niemand ein interesse daran dass sie aus
prinzip einfach da stehen bleiben und
weiter verbreitet werden und von noch
einem monat anderen leuten gesehen
werden das ist natürlich auch nicht von
vorteil deswegen sollte man die
kommentare auch melden damit sie
entfernt werden allerdings erst nachdem
man wie gesichert hat um sie auch zur
anzeige zu bringen jetzt habe ich hier
ein kommentar von dietmar tschohl kopf
auf facebook der meint witte im netz
verfolgen wie sich frauen männer
gegenüber verhalten da schenkt man sich
auf beiden seiten nichts programm ist
denn das tatsächlich was wo man generell
sagen kann da sind frauen völlig frei
von da kann sich die feministische linke
babbel nenne ich es mal oder szene
komplett frei von stellen dass sie keine
digitale gewalt ausübt
also natürlich ist keins der
geschlechter ist in sich einfach
schlecht geboren oder sexistisch oder
hasn't geboren das natürlich albern
jeder mensch egal ob mann frau oder
irgendein geschlechter zwischen hat die
möglichkeit ein troll oder ein händler
im internet zu sein und cybermobbing zu
voll zu vollziehen aber die
sexualisierte gewalt die frauen erleben
also ich meine ich bin jetzt schon seit
vielen jahren als content creation im
öffentlichen raum unterwegs und keiner
meiner zumindest heterosexuellen
männlichen influenza kollegen die ich so
kenne bei db ist von keinem von dem sind
vergewaltigungen an der tagesordnung
also deswegen ich verstehe zwar worauf
der kommentator hier hinaus möchte aber
würde trotzdem sagen dass das einfach
trotzdem zwei unterschiedliche sachen
sind also unterschiedliche relationen ja
also die man die schieren masse auch
einfach
jetzt habe ich einfach mal ein kommentar
von harald zeigt die männer noch an ich
lass mich doch nicht beleidigen wiso
zeigt ihr sie nicht an ja ich komme sagt
ihr habt mich drauf gespielt und da ist
ja immer einfach gesagt finde ich also
wenn es dann um so eine schiere masse
geht von der man fast erschlagen wird es
ist ja auch es ist ja auch etwas das
total viel zeit frisst und auch
ressourcen vielleicht hat nicht jede
frau der das passiert überhaupt den die
finanziellen ressourcen überhaupt sich
einen anwalt zu holen dann ist natürlich
abgesehen von dieser schieren masse und
ob das überhaupt sich lohnt ob man
überhaupt mit so einem fall durch kommt
auch noch mal ne frage sowie ist
überhaupt der stand was justiz und
digitalisierung in deutschland angeht
weil da hinken wir halt auch total
hinterher ich weiß als mir damals als
damals die ersten chips doms über mir
hinein gebrochen sind habe ich
tatsächlich versuchen wir bei der
polizei und bei anwälten hilfe zu suchen
und vielleicht bin ich da nicht an den
richtigen polizisten und nicht an den
richtigen anwalt gelangt vielleicht
hätte ich da bessere leute für finden
können aber als ich das als anfang 20
jährige damals versucht habe werde die
grundsätzliche haltung mehr so ein
schulterzucken
das ist halt im internet internet tut
uns leid da können wir nicht so wirklich
was machen das ist ja ein anonymer user
nehmen und da weiß man ja nicht wer das
ist und wir haben jetzt hier auch nicht
die ressourcen dass du zu herauszufinden
wer das ist das unverständlich dann als
frau schon extrem hilflos ist einfach
das ist tatsächlich auch etwas was ein
gutachten steht ich zitiere mal
expertinnen für geschlechtsbezogene
gewalt haben zu wenig technisches know
how um die betroffenen unterstützen zu
können während expertinnen im bereich
cybercrime zu wenig erfahrung im umgang
mit geschlechtsbezogener gewalt haben
und dann heißt es weiter eine stelle bei
vielen polizeikräften besteht noch
nachholbedarf was die sensibilisierung
für geschlechtsbezogene digitale gewalt
betrifft also hier tatsächlich keine
anekdote sondern festgestellt im
gutachten der für den
gleichstellungsbericht den dritten der
bundesregierung frau ballon woran liegt
denn das wir haben 2021 das internet ist
eigentlich kein neuland mehr und auch
schon relativ alt es gibt generationen
jetzt die damit aufgewachsen sind wieso
hinken wird da gerade in diesem bereich
noch so hinterher
das hat ganz verschiedene gründe
weswegen man das thema leider auch nicht
so eindimensional betrachten kann also
wir haben leider auch immer noch im jahr
20 21 massive defizite wenn es um
sensibilisierung der
strafverfolgungsbehörden geht das
erzählen uns leider immer noch betroffen
also wird auch gerade gehört haben
dass sie abgewiesen wurden dass ihnen
gesagt wurde ja ach lasst doch den
account und was ist überhaupt ein foto
von einem großen rock das ist deine
eigene schuld dass es passiert ist und
das ist natürlich eine katastrophe
insbesondere wenn man bedenkt dass
frauen so häufig von sexualisierten
inhalten und auch von vergewaltigungs
androhungen betroffen sind und es sich
ohnehin schon dreimal überlegen ob sie
überhaupt zur polizeidienststelle um die
ecke gehen um das noch mit dem
männlichen polizeibeamten noch mal alles
zu besprechen und da sind wir auch schon
beim zweiten punkt man muss leider
vielerorts noch zur polizeiwachen gegen
die internetwache sind leider nicht gut
genug ausgestattet und selbst in berlin
ist es so dass man keine sweatshirts
hochladen kann weil es nicht möglich ist
über dieses portal irgendwelche dateien
anzuhängen das heißt man muss man wieder
was ausdrucken man muss es irgendwie im
briefumschlag tun oder eben vorbei gehen
und dass er dort abgeben wenn man die
gesicherten beweise dort einreichen
einem briefumschlag
naja oder man geht halt vorbei also ich
muss das internet ausdrucken tatsächlich
gedacht man muss das internet ausdrucken
und das ist leider ein riesenproblem was
wir haben und zu guter letzt wohl leider
auch die bundesregierung gar nicht im
alleingang abhilfe schaffen kann haben
wir immer noch dieses problem der täter
in den identifizierung im netz ist für
die ermittlungsbehörden wahnsinnig
aufwendig dazu ermitteln die social
media plattform kooperieren nur in
seltenen fällen überhaupt mal mit ihnen
fast schon detektivischer aufwand
dahinter zu kommen mit wem man es zu tun
hat wenn die täter nicht unter klarnamen
agieren und leider sind auch die
rechtlichen möglichkeiten dann
irgendwann mal ausgeschöpft so dass es
selbst wenn dieser ganze aufwand
betrieben wurde noch nicht garantiert
ist dass man dahinter kommt also ich
habe jetzt kann nochmal kommentare so
von big daddy rey zum beispiel männer
werden täglich online beleidigt
besonders gamer warum beschweren sich
die männer im fernsehen nie warum
beschweren sich immer nur frauen wir
machen auch sehr gern mal ins team wenn
sich gamer melden und das thematisieren
ich glaube gaming ist auch besonders
nochmal ein sehr harter teil wo es sehr
hart zur sache geht wird auch in diesem
gutachten tatsächlich genannt gaming
also vielleicht manchmal auch wenn wir
uns drohen zu wiederholen frau ballon
also warum beschweren sich melanie ist
die eine frage und dann vielleicht noch
mal ein paar sätze zu dieser gaming
szene
dass sich männer liebe sperren ist jetzt
auch nicht zutreffend also es gibt ja
durchaus auch männer die auch gegen
digitale gewalt vorgehen weil sie eben
sagen ich lasse mir nicht alles bieten
und ich lasse eben nicht zu dass man so
im internet mit mir spricht und wehre
mich dagegen das ist ja durchaus ja auch
der fall und dann ist es sicherlich so
dass auch im bereich gaming ein etwas
rauer ton herrscht das ist etwas was
auch bekannt ist da gibt es leider auch
viele probleme auch mit hate speech und
ja wenn die männer keine anzeigen
erstatten wollen dann kann ich ihnen
auch nur das gleiche raten die ich jetzt
auch einen frauen rate über denkt diese
haltung und überdenkt ob ihr das einfach
so hinnehmen wollte und beschwert euch
wenn ihr es massenhaft erlebt und wie es
mit der gaming szene also ich weiß aus
eigener erfahrung da kann es ganz schön
zur sache gehen
wir haben das problem dass die gaming
plattformen anders als zum beispiel
facebook und twitter und co eben nicht
reguliert sind das heißt wir haben dann
nicht so komfortable meldewege und auch
rechtliche verpflichtungen innerhalb von
kurzen fristen illegalen inhalten
illegale inhalte zu entfernen es gibt ja
auch studien die irgendwann sich sogar
muss ich sogar gezeigt hat dass diese
gaming plattform für eine gerechte
radikalisierung zu erwecken sind weil
sie eben fernab jeder strafverfolgung
stattfinden das ist tatsächlich ein
problem wo wir uns auch schon länger
dafür aussprechen dass eben hier der
gesetzgeber tätig wird und eben auch
solche plattformen reguliert und dabei
genauer hinguckt was da eigentlich
passiert das hat ja auch schon
gewissermaßen was mit jugendschutz zu
tun um eben jugendliche davor zu
schützen den gleichen inhalten
ausgesetzt zu sein
programm haben sie erfahrungen mit der
gaming szene gemacht früher das war vor
dem internet noch
was ich sehr spannend finde ist es was
ja der kommentator gerade eben auch
aufgebracht hat dass männer sich
scheinbar nicht so oft beschwerden auch
wenn ihnen das auch passiert wie hinten
der gaming community auch ist er ein
sehr männerdominiert oder jungs
dominiertes fällt ist es auch im offline
leben so dass zum beispiel gewalt die
männer auf der straße erfahren meistens
von anderen männern konnte nicht von
anderen frauen insofern finde ich das
immer ein ganz ganz interessanten
mechanismus dass sobald wir öffentlich
ein gespräch darüber führen dass frauen
an der gewalt von männern leiden das
dann manche männer dann in diese
diskussion kommen und dann schlagartig
sagen ja aber männer leiden auch unter
gewalt und wir wollen nicht darüber ja
aber männer leiden auch unter gewalt von
anderen männern also die gewalt die
männer von frauen angetan wird ist
sowohl offline als auch online
tatsächlich die ausnahme die die regel
bestätigt und gerade wenn wir auch von
der radikalisierung von jungen männern
auf solchen gaming portalen oder
plattformen wie rettet oder freud schen
sprechen glaube ich ist es auch ganz
ganz eine ganz interessante und wichtige
debatte die wir haben sollten in was für
einer krise die männlichkeit gerade
steckt mit sicherheit auch weil wir
schon in der vierten generation sind
also wir frauen darüber darüber zu
sprechen was eigentlich unsere rolle in
der gesellschaft ist und dass wir gleich
gestellt werden wollen und diese
notwendigkeit für diese konversation
dass ein das eigene
geschlechterrollen bild zu reformieren
und zu erneuern da gab es die
notwendigkeit für männer bisher noch gar
nicht und ich denke dass junge männer in
einer sehr großen sinn krise stecken und
das ja viel sexistischer hass und auch
zum beispiel sehr viel rechte
radikalisierung daraus entspringt und
dass das wahrscheinlich kernfragen sind
die wir stellen sollten jetzt habe ich
hier noch so ein paar kommentare die
gehen in die richtung also das problem
an termin ist in ist das ja auch alle
männer über einen kamm scheren und damit
keinen deut besser sind als die die sie
kritisieren wollen dazu kommen noch dass
die teilweise recht bizarre argumente
bringen ich möchte jetzt keine
feministische diskussion an anbringen
das geht er so um die art und weise wie
man kommuniziert
waldfee 123 schreibt auch so langsam
auch andere meinungen akzeptiert und
nicht nur die einige als das einzig
richtige ansieht kommt erst gar keine
hetze auf viele von den aktivisten
verlangen von anderen toleranz und sind
es selber überhaupt nicht was entgegnen
sie das programm ja es gibt ja auch
dieses paradox irgendwie der diplomatie
also diplomatie funktioniert und
toleranz funktioniert ja auch nur bis zu
einem gewissen punkt wir können nicht
rechtes gedankengut zum beispiel oder
homophobie gedankengut einfach als
meinung ab tun und sagen ja das gehört
aber auch zu einer demokratischen
gesellschaft und wenn homosexuelle
toleranz wollen dann sollte man auch
homophoben menschen toleranz geben weil
die freiheiten des lebens für
homosexuelle menschen gehören genau da
auf wo wir den homophoben menschen zu
viel spielraum geben
insofern ich verstehe zwar was der
kommentator diese kommentatoren sagen
möchte aber ich gehe da nicht mit ein
youtuber der sich immer wieder auch sehr
kritisch über feministische oder
rassistische videos äußert gerade aus
dem funknetzwerk ist dem hält auch
bekannt als kuchen tv wurde auch in den
kommentaren hier schon ausreichend
erwähnt uns wird vorgeworfen wir würden
extra content für ihn machen damit er
wieder einen raschen video machen kann
ich würde eher fragen warum er sich
immer wieder an diesen beiträgen
abarbeitet aber wir werden ja sehen ob
es das ganze gibt wir haben ein
aktuelles ein eigener maßen aktuelles
beispiel wo genau das passiert ist es
gab ein zdf zoom in beitrag auf youtube
und tim hält hat darauf reagiert
er kümmert sich in der pandemie oftmals
um die kinder die mütter der anteil der
familien in denen die frau die
kinderbetreuung vollständig übernimmt
hat sich im vergangenen jahr von 8 auf
16 verdoppelt ok und wo genau ist jetzt
ein punkt wenn ich in meiner familie
abspreche dass beispielsweise die frau
zu hause bleibt und ich als man weiter
arbeiten gehe dann hat das ja nichts
mehr benachteiligung zu tun weil wir als
familie das gemeinsam abgesprochen haben
und die frau wurde da wahrscheinlich
auch gefragt was sie machen möchte ich
verstehe ehrlich gesagt den punkt nicht
so ganz auf den ihr hinaus wollt hier
wäre zum beispiel eine mögliche ursache
dass frauen eher in branche arbeiten die
während corinna geschlossen gewesen sind
also zum beispiel im restaurant oder
hotel gewerbe ich hab's mal erlebt dass
ich gleichzeitig mit einem mann
eingestellt wurde für die gleiche arbeit
und monate später haben wir dann über
unser gehalt gesprochen und dann kam
raus dass ich 230 euro pro tag verdient
habe und er 280 das ist halt einfach
genauso dumm und hat jetzt auch einfach
null aussagekraft erstmal natürlich auch
quelle vertrauen ihr bruder aber ich
will hier auch gar nicht vorwerfen dass
das nicht stimmen aber wenn du solche
reportagen wie das veröffentlicht dann
brauchst du dich nicht wundern dass du
weniger verdienen zwar anscheinend bist
du nicht wirklich gut darin
so also ein hartes urteil
frau ballon solche aussagen und die
wiederholte in diesem video immer mal
wieder und sagt also dass kein wunder
dass du nicht mehr verdienst weil du
kannst es einfach nicht ist das schon
justiziabel oder ist das einfach
irgendwas was man aushalten muss
ich habe mir das video auch angesehen
und er muss sagen dass ich doch einst
von der meinungsfreiheit gedeckt
einstufen würde auch wenn ich diese
meiner vielleicht nicht teile aber ist
es etwas wo man dann sagen das ok also
wo ist also was hätte man sagen müssen
sich morgen mit den bereich schmähkritik
zugehen
wenn wir natürlich mit beschimpfungen
und fäkalsprache zu tun gehabt hätten
oder wenn wir tatsächlich völlig
isoliert von der von der
auseinandersetzung mit dem inhalt des
zdf beitrag hier beschimpfungen gesehen
hätten die sich auch dirk gegen die
moderatorin richten dann hätten wir
schon mit beleidigungen zu tun das ist
allerdings noch eher grenzwertig und ich
würde eher sagen noch keine beleidigung
also du bist zu dumm ist keine
beleidigung
in dem beitrag gerade hat er nicht er
gesagt du bist du dumm sondern dann bist
du offenbar nicht besonders gut darin
und das sehe ich noch als moderate
kritik ok also gut formulierte moderator
kritik dir dieser erhält kuchen tv hat
sich ja oft aber auch an ihm
abgearbeitet fragen welche konsequenzen
hat das denn für sie
ganz ganz viele zwölfjährige trolle
wie
die nur genervt haben oder wo es halt
total
80 kuchen tv dann hinterher gehen und
mich dann auf meinem social media
plattformen dann belästigen aber
mittlerweile sich das meer so mit einem
mit einem lachenden und mit einem
weinenden auge
jetzt ist schon ein bisschen lustig ja
also auch diese überheblichkeit dass er
wirklich als kanal zerstörer unterwegs
ist und sämtliche
beiträge die von journalisten und
redaktionen im feministischen bereich
erarbeitet wurden also in diesen in
diesem thematischen inhalt arbeiten und
wirklich denkt dass er dass er das alles
besser weiß und besser versteht und
besser recherchiert als all diese zig
journalisten die das einfach
hauptberuflich machen da das verdient
fast schon kleine klaus deml aber
applaus
ich habe ja noch ein paar kommentare
einmal geht es um das quad das ist ja
das was für das genick benutzt wird
häufig von sika gemeint sind nur kerle
im diskurs kommt eine frau dazu wird die
so lange beleidigt dass die rausgeht und
das passiert täglich ist das etwas was
sie bestätigen können
entsprechend kann ich kann ich
bestätigen
das haben wir leider auch schon des
öfteren gehört dass sie sich das genau
so abspielt und das ist vor allem auch
eine sehr frauenfeindliche haltung in
solchen gaming pad gibt weswegen geben
frauen sich da auch schon gar nicht mehr
wo es wegen so und dann eine frage von
hubert hölzl peter altmaier wird ständig
aufgrund seiner körperform belächelt
gibt es auch immer wieder satiriker die
sich an ihm abarbeiten ist die sexuelle
gewalt
nun wenn wir bei satire sprechen
entsprechend mehr über kunden und das
hatten wir auch schon angesprochen den
politischen meinungskampf dann muss man
sich dann eben auch mal überspitzte
kritik gefallen lassen aber wenn die
kritik immer in die richtung geht der
mann ist zu viel ist jan inhaltlich
nicht irgendwie
gibt es ja keine kritik in was ja auch
bayern altmaier ist natürlich nicht
erlaubt ich ohne angst eine
auseinandersetzung mit politischen
positionen mit irgendwelchen inhalten an
ihm abzuarbeiten und dann da natürlich
rein auf äußerlichkeiten beschränkt ihn
zu beschimpfen und zu beleidigen am ende
des tages auch das ist nicht erlaubt und
sollte genauso ernst genommen werden wie
andere phänomene die wir heute schon
gesprochen haben so wir kriegen jetzt
sehr viel liebe dafür dass wir uns hier
kurz mit kuchen tv beschäftigt haben das
nehmen wir jetzt mal einfach so an wir
haben ihn nicht eingeladen weil das ist
hier gerade nicht um tatsächlich diesen
aspekt geht sondern das war jetzt
einfach mal ein beispiel dafür wie so
etwas aussehen kann und wir wollten
einfach auch ganz gerne wissen inwiefern
das jetzt tatsächlich von der
meinungsfreiheit gedeckt ist das haben
wir geklärt ich hatte hier noch eine
frage
bezüglich
digitaler gewalt und strafbarkeit geht
auch an frau ballon körperverletzung ist
strafbar dass es bekannt will marko
friedrich wissen gibt es konkrete
tatbestände für digitale gewalt
digitale gewalt steht als solches jetzt
nicht im strafgesetzbuch aber natürlich
gibt es straftatbestände die wir
regelmäßig im digitalen bereich sehen
das sind natürlich die beleidigung und
die verleugnung
auch die bedrohung das sehen wir auch
häufiger in form von morddrohungen oder
auch zum beispiel dass straftaten
einfach gejubelt oder bejubelt und
gefeiert werden auch das ist kann eine
straftat erfüllen wir sehen aber auch
zum beispiel das bildmaterial
missbraucht wird das bildmaterial auch
irgendeiner form verändert verbreitet
wird auch das ist strafbar und wir sehen
auch das fake profile eingerichtet
werden und dass menschen mit brille
lässt nicht werden das kann dann eben
auch schon stalking sein denn stalking
gibt es auch im digitalen bereich so
jetzt mittels hier
wir kriegen viel feedback auf diesen
stream nicht unbedingt positiven gerade
schreibt niklas bis jetzt habe ich ein
kanal sendern gefreut aber wenn ihr so
was offensichtlich ist außerdem sind wir
so was offensichtlich aus dem
zusammenhang reißen weiß man ja gar
nicht was bei euch noch so stimmt nicht
dass du kannst du sehr gerne nochmal
reinschreiben was wir aus dem
zusammenhang gerissen haben sollen weil
ich weiß dass jetzt gerade nicht ich
kenne beide videos und wir haben das so
zusammengeschnitten die ist in
zusammengeschnitten gehört
und ich glaube hier gab es irgendwie
noch mal was
von euch hätte ich deutlich was besseres
erwartet johannes sagt mir auch gerne
was du besser als erwartet hätte ist wir
versuchen hier einfach ein einen diskurs
zu fördern und auch darüber zu reden die
frauen von digitaler gewalt betroffen
sind wenn du dann noch was zu beisteuern
kann es sehr gerne so
auf den kommentar geht es nicht
frau bleibe was haben sie denn jetzt
gemacht um sich gegen solche digitale
gewalt zu schützen
ich habe es mit polizei und anwälten
versucht das hat mich so richtig
geklappt dann habe ich mich eine weile
lang aus dem internet zurückgezogen habe
hier und da mal die plattform gewechselt
ich halte zum beispiel twitter und
youtube für wesentlich toxischer als die
kommentarspalte auf instagram
beispielsweise da ist doch alles noch
recht fleißig unterwegs
ich bin zur therapie gegangen
ich habe teilweise auch mit menschen die
in diesem bereich arbeiten gesprochen
also die irgendwie selbst politisch
feministische inhalte machen und denen
ganz ganz ähnliche sachen passiert sind
so dass man durch diese gespräche auch
irgendwie merkt okay das ist tatsächlich
ein phänomen das hat eigentlich gar
nichts mit mir persönlich zutun sondern
es ist einfach wie es ist frauen die in
der öffentlichkeit sind sollten zu
politischen dingen am besten nicht ihre
meinung sagen vor allem nicht wenn sie
links sind
das sind so verschiedene sachen die mir
geholfen haben aber therapie und ein
gutes umfeld und ein netzwerk von
anderen menschen denen das gleiche
passiert ist das hat mir auf jeden fall
geholfen ist heute ein wenig gelassener
zu sehen auch wenn ich noch immer
absolut nicht in ordnung finde so es
gibt jetzt hier noch kritik an uns von
es geht auch ganz großer journalismus
zwei gäste einladen die dieselben
ansichten haben und dann über eine
dritte person lästern stark erstens wir
haben nicht gebessert ich glaube lässt
dann ist wirklich was anderes zweitens
es gibt glaube ich zu dem thema digitale
gewalt es ist schwierig verschiedene
ansichten zu haben denn digitale gewalt
ist einfach nichts wo man sagen kann das
ist in ordnung und darf man darüber
diskutieren hat digitale gewalt gut oder
schlecht ist sie ist real sie ist da und
es gibt sie eben auch gegen männer und
gegen frauen nur müssen wir feststellen
dass haben wir gerade mit frau ballon
schon besprochen das stellen wir auch in
dem gutachten der sachverständigen fest
sie richtet sich besonders gegen frauen
und darüber reden wir jetzt so jetzt
sehe ich hier gaben noch das kuchen tv
erhält reagiert live auf seinem
twitter-kanal auf uns schön groß raus
ich bin gespannt wie man das macht live
auf einen einen livestream auf einen
live stream zu machen ist eine ganz
schöne ganz schöne leistung aber ich
gucke mir das nachher gern noch mal an
ich würde sagen an dieser stelle machen
wir den stream noch jetzt mal zu wir
haben glaube ich über alles geredet was
wichtig ist ich bedanke mich bei frau
ballon und bei frau crime ich bedanke
mich auch bei euch kritik immer gerne
ihr wisst wir sind dafür offen wir
stellen uns dem ganzen wir drücken uns
nicht weg und wir zeigen auch wenn hier
etwas gibt was euch nicht gefällt in
diesem sinne sagt blatt munter macht
weiter bis zum nächsten mal und tschüss